documenting the transition isn't easy
but there's mounting evidence already
suggesting the new taliban is very much
like the old
human rights group amnesty international
has documented through photographic and
eyewitness testimony a massacre of nine
hazara men six were shot and three
others were tortured to death
they were killed between the 4th and 6th
of july in the eastern province of
ghazni the hazara have long faced
persecution in afghanistan and amnesty
says the killings
are a horrific indicator of what taliban
rule may bring particularly for
minorities
there's also evidence the taliban's
rounding up afghans who worked with the
fallen governments or u.s and british
forces one example mentioned in a u.n
intelligence report happened on tuesday
this week
men believed to be the taliban went to
the home of a former counter-terrorism
officer in kabul
and they gave him this letter
it said you're asked to present yourself
at the military and intelligence
commission and provide information in
relation to your cooperation with the
americans and the british should you
fail to attend at the above mentioned
address
members of your family will be arrested
and you'll have no right to complain and
you would carry the responsibility
now the report author says it's an
extremely worrying development
they directly went to the apartments of
these individuals
if they didn't arrest them they
they would go for their families instead
and as i've come out in the media also
uh in the last 24 hours uh incidences of
of of uh
killings of family members uh to other
journalists to interpreters and and
others so
we can expect these things to uh to be
happening uh most likely at a more
systematic scale ahead
what is different about the new taliban
is an awareness of their image abroad
something we've not seen before there is
no huge skepticism about their carefully
chosen words and their new presentation
governments around the world are
struggling to understand what exactly it
all means and form coherent foreign
policies
but the targeted killings and the
treatment of women in some areas
suggests the projection of a reformed
taliban
may just be for the cameras